at the beginning of a romantic comedy is
it best that the two leads hate each
other or intensely dislike each other
does that make us more you know if it's
if it's too easygoing one I mean that's
boring in some sense why do we why are
we intrigued by the two you know whether
it's the co-workers or you know whatever
just you know sort of the college friend
that always sort of made fun of you or
something like that why is that
something that's we're intrigued by I
think it goes back again to your
question about opposites attracting and
you you're not going to get any sparks
if you agree all the time this is just
not going to be interesting you know
give me somebody who challenges me also
I I have this thing I call cheetah love
and little baby cheetahs when they're
learning how to hunt you know the mom
takes them out and shows them how to
pounce and how to grab prey and how to
eat it if you walk in to where they are
and the little baby cheetahs are just
sitting around maybe it's not quite time
to go hunting yet but they're going to
be going soon you laid down a big chunk
of bloody raw meat in front of them
they'll just look at it
they don't recognize it as lunch unless
it's running away a lot of us are the
same way about romance
we love the chase and we don't show any
interest if it's not running away so
it's part of part of some people's human
nature that they like the chase they
want to conquer something they feel that
if I didn't have to pay a price for it
it must not be worth it and that's a
hard thing when people then do get
together and the chase is over it's
often difficult then to keep the romance
going if that's been a major part of the
relationship at the beginning so is it a
good idea to start people at the
beginning of a rom-com at disparate
sides of something absolutely absolutely
because part of the fun of a rom-com is
the chase and then they get separated
and okay now how are they going to get
back together we know what
it's gonna happen we just don't know how
and that's the fun of rom-coms yes it's
a predictable genre absolutely that's
why we watch it because we know it's
going to end happily or a bittersweet
maybe but we want to see how the chase
goes what tricks do they use to win each
other back or what sacrifices do they
have to make to endear themselves again
to the person that they realize they
love it takes something where maybe it's
not someone who's chasing the the
playboy but I'm thinking of the movie
green card you'd mention Andie MacDowell
earlier and Gerard Depardieu where
they're both supposed to go in to be
married and they have to pretend that
they know each other so those types of
scenarios where it's not really that
anybody's totally at odds because I
don't think if I remember correctly if
they were it was just that they were put
into this situation it's so it's this
weird thing where they end up falling
for one another accidentally kind of
thing I don't know what that that
storyline is but I've seen it before
that sort of accidental discovery of one
another where it wasn't intended yes you
see that also in it happened to one
night and you've got a reporter and a
rich girl and you know he's trying to
get a story she's trying to get back
with her fiance who she's only engaged
to to make her dad mad because her
billionaire dad is over controlling and
so these two people come together with a
specific goal which is to get her back
to her fiance and for the story the
other reporter to get this story but
along the way then they have to pretend
like they're married and once they do
that then the accident of pretending as
if sets off even more sparks and that
indeed is a good trope for romantic
comedies where people are thrown
together and wouldn't have even thought
that they'd like each other but once
they step into a different role with
each other
and the whole pretending to be married
or pretending to be together is a very
good one I think we see that in real
life okay next time you're at the
grocery store look at the tabloids look
at those magazines what are they all
about actors and actresses who were
playing at being in love and fell in
love how often do you see that happening
the point of it is when you start acting
as if you often make it so and it's a
it's a wonderful device for romantic
comedies
you